hey guys how's it going welcome to cards
against humanity' so you guys love this
and we do too the last game was a lot of
fun so we decide to give it a go with
the remaining cards that we got left
so same old deal it is done in this
fashion
[Music]
oh and so when we will go to
best-of-five and that'll be the end of
it
Rando will be included in this one as
well and then we will see how it goes so
alright oh no we get dropped really
uncomfortable everybody out there how am
I compensating for my tiny penis my
minuscule tiny penis
how many compensating for my tiny penis
grandpa's ashes swiftly achieving orgasm
for her sudden penis loss
I'm sad I'm gonna go with swiftly
achieving orgasm for her random random
his new self-produced album Kanye waist
raps whoa everybody a waste say that
again
I said raps they're self-produced album
Kanye West's raps over the sounds of
blank okay it's good no he's really
funny
we're not laughing at you by the way I
want to be very clear you said you said
Wiest said Kanye West and then what's it
over the sounds of a man on the brink of
orgasm over the sounds of teenage
pregnancy and over the sounds of
depression just read out the things in
his new self-produced album Kanye West's
raps over the sounds of a man on the
brink of orgasm teenage pregnancy and
depression or depression all of them
it's just one new rap album it's does
sound like actually no way this is a
story man on the brink of or go
teenage pregnancy depression I just this
this is what I think would be the
funniest listening to music wise yeah
because or listening to Kanye rapping
because what is the sound of yeah it's
normally the complete and utter silence
so he's just rapping in silence so it's
like just drink sound of a single tear
so I think of this as Kanye West reading
poetry so depression wins yeah blank kid
tested mother approved walking in on me
kiss kid tested mother approved not
believing in giraffe walking in on dad
peeing into mom's mouth is the winner
yeah yes hi this is Jim from accounting
we noticed a 12 under dollar charge
labeled blank could you explain hi this
is Jim from accounting we noticed a
$1200 charge labeled getting your dick
stuck in a Chinese finger drop with
another tick explain this label dismiss
[Music]
12 a little charge label mouth herpes
explain when all else fails I can always
masturbate to blink
I can always masturbate to permanent
orgasm face this masturbate to dying
alone and in pain my reality turns
what's your reality here dying is open
to you you can do anything we can't
we're all 27 word I aim yes I am
sweeping oh I don't I actually have no
idea my girls faces
cuz I've never looked in a mirror gir
horrifying ya know why anyone would want
that just like naked me in the mirror oh
[Laughter]
that's so saying it's weird yeah nothing
I like that no you're just in a room
full of the mirror so you can't escape
[Music]
circle-jerk
yeah but no I've never seen my own okay
so neither have I
what's yours
[Laughter]
please tell me to smile behind every
powerful man is good to go no no I'm
just remembering cuz it's always gonna
be burned in my brain completely from
the side go forward behind every
powerful man is behind every power is
[Laughter]
[Music]
like they cut it out and put it
34 because you only choose like one
second the blind day was going horribly
until we discovered our shared interest
in blank so the blind date was going
horribly until we discovered our shared
interest in teaching a girl how to know
teaching a girl how to handle VP sorry
the blind date would go horribly and do
we discovered our shared interest in a
vagina then leads to another dimension
now yeah portal intercourse say that
love inter portal intercourse the blind
a was gonna orderly until we discovered
our shared interest in whipping an
obedience late a disobedient slave
that's your honest super interested does
it like shock you through like does it
immediately enter into some other
species basically your penis goes
through the dimension it could it could
it could go through like multiple
interdimensional vaginas so you're
[ __ ] one you're [ __ ] the universe
[Music]
why am i stinks that's my Akash why is
he sticky oh yeah get your orgasms out
of your ear listen gosh I am sticky
because of flying insects snakes
I am sticky because the amount of gay I
am finally a service that delivers blank
right to your door finally a service
that delivers shaft right to your door
now is this the movie shaft or is it up
to me okay
finally a service that delivers super
suicidal thoughts right to your door
finally a service that delivers penis
envy right to your door turns out that
Blankman was neither the hero we needed
nor wanted turns out that was neither
the we needed or wanted it turns out
that party Mexicans man
was neither of at your who we needed nor
one now that sounds cool party Mexican
soup again with like
turns out that Boris the Soviet love
hammer
I love party Mexicans but it's it
doesn't fit the criteria so I got a
limit that what we really don't need
black in this place yeah that's the one
I pick yes Boris the Soviet love I just
like the idea of love hammer man yeah
God a successful job interview begins
with the firm handshake and ends with
play a successful job interview begins
with a firm handshake and ends with my
dead son space successful job interview
begins with
[Music]
what has been making life difficult at
the nudist colony mark you could win
with this one if you choose the right
card what has been making life difficult
at the nudist colony a snapping turtle
biting off the tip of your penis
oh very possible surprise sex boob
explosion disease see the surprise sex
oh this is that big turtle biting off
the difference your penis is a tough one
both both very possible scenarios in the
nudist colony I'm gonna go with the
snapping turtle yeah I was Randall I was
poop yeah I don't want to win yet let's
go to a set let's go I never truly
understood blank until I encountered
blank I never truly understood a
Japanese tourist who wants something
very badly but can't communicate it
until Anders until I encountered going
to a high school reunion
I never truly understood breastfeeding a
ten-year-old until I encountered making
the penises kiss I never truly
understood wifely duties until I
encountered injection the inside another
man's wave all of them very I gotta go
with this there you go good job you did
it I did it I did it should we should we
bump it up to ten cards sad about your
options yeah that's the challenge of the
game you gotta make it funny yeah I got
99 problems but that ain't one I got 99
problems but AIDS monkeys anyone I'm
glad I'm really happy for you man
motions oh good good I think I think
that's standard for most males you
produce so much every day
how much do you masturbate so much the
smells are so used to mass produce II
know the male the average male produces
like millions of sperm every day oh yeah
but this is even true not the same thing
running out of yeah [ __ ] him on a fire
you are home bow before on a fire
I'm on fire this month's Cosmo spice up
your sex life by bringing blank into the
bedroom
this month's Cosmo spice up your sex
life by bringing September 11 2001 into
the bedroom at our costume that
somebody's in in there this does not
dive deeper into this I imagine that the
plane was this month's Cosmo spice up
your sex life by bringing getting eaten
alive by Guy Fieri into the bedroom okay
this is this month's Cosmo spice up your
sex life by bringing ancient Athenian
boys that is cards against humanity'
once again we've gone down a path of
horribleness but hey we learned a lot of
things out of this one our old faces
[Music]
like a chicken getting some seed anyway
so that's guys again humanity don't take
all this too seriously of course - do
you guys know our cards against
humanity' is it's horrible and that's
the whole point so thank you everybody
so much for watching let us know what
you thought of it down in the comments
below check out Ethan's channel in the
description check out Tyler's Twitter
and channel in the description so thanks
again and as always we will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]